senior NBA rider from ESPN's undefeated
back here on the show Marc Spears how
you been Marc I would say so so I give
you the floor cuz I'm not surprised but
I'm still shocked I can't believe LeBron
is gonna be a Laker Marc yeah exactly
with you because like all the tea leaves
were there right the fire was burning
like I I heard his son's gun was
enrolled at a high school Sierra Canyon
already in LA I heard he was hired an
assistant that was going to move to LA I
heard that his agent rich Paul was going
to go full-time in LA like everything
was pointing in LA Maverick Carter his
guy having lunch with magic and there's
a like all the signs were there but I'm
with you until it like actually happened
you're like wow wow
and I actually loved out the way he did
it and I wrote about it and undefeated
but to just put it out in the email and
send it out as an attachment to the NBA
reporters and Cavs writers was certainly
much different than the decision yeah
and then take off for Europe apparently
and then just not even have a press
conference which is completely anathema
to what the Lakers normally do I mean
they're they're all about Showtime which
is part of the reason why lebron coming
is so big that kind of lends to I think
how it will because you know one thing
I've loved about the Lakers from John
black - Allison bog Lee - PR folks there
was that they've always been really
really open and allowing the media to
speak to the players you could always
get Shaq they didn't rush you you could
always get Kobe they didn't rush you I
think LeBron is going to be different
you know
it's he was definitely had a circle
around him in Cleveland obviously you
see the move here and I expect him on
media day at their facility probably
just to have the big press conference
style thing to announce his arrival
which wouldn't come until late September
so now what how does this all fit
together then Marc I mean because here
he is telling Magic Johnson
take your time you know don't don't give
up the farm for Kauai right now I trust
you let's give you I'll give you three
plus one to try and figure it out what
is his mindset do you think in the
autumn of his NBA years mark obviously I
don't know if it's about a championship
at the moment the roster doesn't say so
I do like the young players but I think
this has got to be an excitement and
intrigue about going to LA rich you know
this because I've seen you at Lakers
games when you go there all the business
that's talked about courtside it is
phenomenal you see these old guys that
you may not realize you might notice the
celebrities but there's some old guys
around the court that make big money
deals so you're gonna see rich Paul and
you're gonna see maverick Carter
basically every game talking to the
movers of the shakers in LA and taking
care of LeBrons business for the future
like people say well you know he's a
Bryant he doesn't need to do that but
you're instead of being a far you're
gonna they're gonna be there tonight on
a regular basis amongst the Hollywood
execs and the money of California I
think regardless of whether he wins
anything or not from a long-term
financial play this is a great move for
us career so you're saying if he's
trying to be like Magic Johnson in any
way with this deal it's more about the
current iteration of Magic rather than
the playing era of Magic winning
championships for the Lakers which is
obviously important I mean you know
Green besides him on that Florida no
James Worthy so I mean to me that's what
it has to be about look the dust may
settle in Kawhi Leonard could be there
it seems like from a free agency
standpoint it'd be tough to get cousins
or any anybody else noteworthy not that
there's a lot left but if he was in a
rush to win another championship
he definitely needs to be patient there
because this is the Western Conference
it's a little different much tougher
style here the Warriors are still great
the Houston Rockets are still great Utah
still great
Dallas is about to be much better right
now if I look at it I mean the Lakers
are definitely in the playoffs but I
definitely don't agree with them having
the second best size in the NBA about
that mark 7 to 2 right now in Las Vegas
Nevada better than the Rockets odds
right now only the Warriors have a
better odds to win or worse odds is more
expected based on a sports book in Las
Vegas Nevada that's but wouldn't you
agree though that the that this roster
is better than the roster he he took to
the finals in the east mark I think
we're a little hard on that roster that
they did have another all-star
I think Kuzma has the ability to be an
all-star Brandon Ingram perhaps but they
haven't done it yet is Julius Randle
back we don't know you know so it's it's
hard for me to say right now I think
it's a good roster but I also think that
um you know you're expecting a lot from
some really young guys which at least
I'm from the Cleveland standpoint those
guys were veterans so what's more
surprising to you mark Spears that Paul
George with an opportunity to go to the
Lakers and join LeBron did not or the
fact that LeBron goes to the Lakers with
nobody else already in place of the Paul
George status giving Magic Johnson more
than just a one plus one to figure it
out the former and but I blame the
Lakers for it like they had their
opportunity they could have trade that
number to pick and got him and they felt
like they didn't need to do it there the
Lakers we don't need to make trade that
pick you know we'll get our meeting and
I applaud Sam Presti from the Thunder he
was aggressive
he got Paul George in place they gave
him a great sales job he fell in love a
plan
Russell Westbrook and PG didn't even
consider it I think if the Lakers would
have taken that number to pick and
traded it for Paul he'd be a Laker with
LeBron right now so I kind of blame the
Lakers on that one that's the poll
question of Mark spirits before we we
let him go hey Mark what year do you
think we'll brawn wins a championship
with the Lakers four year deal you're
one year two year three or four or never
really why do you say that I guess I
guess that's what we have to figure out
is when all the dust settles is is is
who has actually improved themselves to
try and take on the Warriors yeah where
is it pretty good at the moment the way
I mean hey people could coming but
lawyers are pretty good what if Kawhi
comes to Los Angeles and teams up what
do you think then okay then you got rid
of Kuzma prolly or some of their young
guys Ingram is gone
the team's great I just think the
Warriors are phenomenal but what if you
just sit there and wait cuz this year's
gonna be a circus and fans even with
LeBron here don't expect a championship
now and magics already been on record
saying it's a to summer it's it's a long
race so kawaiii good but when you got
LeBron James on the roster Championships
are expected and what do you hear about
Kawhi is it possible he hangs out the
entire year sits out the entire year is
that an entire pair is that a
possibility I find that hard to believe
you can't do that from a from a
reputation standpoint
Kyrie Irving was threatening to do that
as well and I actually think Cleveland
shoulda allowed him to sit and wait
cuz they'd still have them right now I
wouldn't trade it out Kyrie so I mean
yeah Kawhi has a lot I think he'll get
moved it probably could happen but yeah
I mean San Antonio was in a really bad
place man really tough place with this
well and
in the last 30 seconds I have with you
here is this different from the NFL
because in the NFL you need to still if
you hold out an entire year you do not
get a year of service accrued towards a
free agency you need to come back and
play a certain number of games for that
to happen is that not the case in the
NBA this is new territory so I don't
know but I don't I don't think so but I
you can't pay them right I would think
you'd want that pretty good check I mean
it sounds tough and sounds like very
very chest poking out I can't see him
doing that but why do you want somebody
that doesn't want to be there ultimately
as a thing so I I'm sure he gets moved
it's just like when will the Lakers the
Lakers know they got the power so I
think they're gonna they're gonna try to
just you know basically say take it or
leave it
Markham's even it might and might be
ending up with nothing at all so mark
appreciate the knowledge as always well
chat soon
we're now in the home of LeBron so I'm
sure we'll see you soon said again I was
about to say I was both say okay mark
we'll chat soon you got it that's at
mark with a CJ Spears ESPN check out his
new column on ESPN's undefeated and what
what it caught his attention was the way
that LeBron announced his decision 3.0
completely different from 1.0 and
definitely different from 2.0 the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience